[Aplausos]
[Música]
esta es la pregunta del millón de euros
porque europa no crece pensadlo bien la
unión europea es la segunda economía del
mundo sólo por detrás de eeuu sin
embargo de las 50 empresas más grandes
del planeta sólo 8 están en suelo
europeo
[Música]
mientras la bolsa de nueva york está aún
fire los mercados de valores europeos
están en números rojos y eso incluye la
bolsa de frankfurt la de parís y por
supuesto la de madrid y qué me decís de
los gigantes tecnológicos todos hemos
oído hablar de google de apple o de
amazon pero cuál sería su equivalente en
europa por supuesto que algo hay porque
tiene que haber de todo en alemania
tienen sap que se dedican a las bases de
datos en suecia tienen spotify pero
vamos que ninguna de estas empresas le
llegan a la suela de los zapatos a un
facebook o un número cualquiera y esto
es especialmente problemático si tenemos
en cuenta que la economía mundial está
en pleno auge
[Música]
mis queridos amigos de visual política
si juntamos el pib de todos los países
del planeta tanto los ricos como los
pobres tenemos un crecimiento del 3,1
por ciento que no está nada mal sin
embargo la unión europea a duras penas
llega al 2,5 por ciento y creedme esto
no son buenas noticias poco crecimiento
implica pocos trabajos y poco dinero
para todos a fin de cuentas si cualquier
empresa china o estadounidense se come
el mercado es cuestión de tiempo que las
empresas europeas se hundan así que
buena suerte buscando un buen trabajo y
buscando un buen sueldo y precisamente
por eso muchos políticos europeos creen
que europa tiene que apostar por las
grandes empresas pues bien en este
contexto es donde tuvo lugar esta
noticia de principios de 2019
[Música]
la unión europea' bloquea la fusión de
alstom siemens debido a las
preocupaciones por la competencia
básicamente la idea era la siguiente
alstom es una empresa francesa que
fabrica trenes de alta velocidad habéis
visto alguna vez los tv franceses esos
que salían en 'misión imposible' pues
están fabricados por alstom siemens es
una empresa alemana con una división que
también fabrica trenes de alta velocidad
[Aplausos]
si estas dos empresas se hubieran
fusionado habrían creado la segunda
empresa más grande del sector de
fabricación de trenes y cuál es la
primera es exacto una empresa china
es decir que de nuevo europa quiere
competir con china en el mundo de la
tecnología y os preguntaréis por qué ha
prohibido la fusión y es aquí donde
llegamos a uno de los grandes dilemas
económicos la base del libre mercado es
la competencia entre empresas es decir
que si muchas empresas luchan por
conseguir más clientes terminarán
ofreciendo mejores bienes y servicios y
a mejor precio
ahora bien qué pasa cuando una empresa
se hace tan grande que se come a las
demás en este caso podríamos llegar a
hablar de un monopolio por ejemplo
imaginad qué pasaría si alstom siemens
se hubieran fusionado en este momento el
gobierno de españa' vamos a imaginar
necesita comprar nuevos trenes para sus
redes de alta velocidad si solamente hay
una única empresa capaz de cumplir con
los requisitos ya me diréis vosotros
para que iban a bajar el precio a fin de
cuentas son la única alternativa pero no
sólo eso también podrían evitar que
nacieran nuevos negocios y terminarían
imponiendo sus condiciones
y que terminaríamos con lo opuesto a lo
que entendemos por el libre mercado por
otra parte hasta qué punto es bueno que
el estado o en este caso la unión
europea se meta a decidir lo que hace o
deja de hacer una empresa como veis
hablamos de un dilema en toda regla y
también de uno de los grandes debates
ideológicos de nuestro tiempo por
supuesto que no saldrá muchas veces en
los medios de comunicación porque no es
la típica pelea simplona entre libre
mercado y socialismo más bien podríamos
decir que es una pugna entre dos
versiones distintas del capitalismo
capitalismo la francesa y capitalismo a
la alemana así que la pregunta es ha
sido una buena idea bloquear la fusión
de alstom siemens y queremos decir con
eso de capitalismo francés y capitalismo
alemán de verdad europa necesita grandes
gigantes económicos para poder crecer
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes antes voy a hacer un
paréntesis veréis tengo una amiga que
tiene un hijo de siete años y este niño
de siete años tiene leucemia la leucemia
es una de esas enfermedades que te
pueden llevar a la tumba
y afecta sobre todo a los niños ya las
niñas si queréis más información en este
vídeo lo explican fenomenal el caso es
que la leucemia se puede curar se puede
curar si te hacen un trasplante de
médula ósea el problema es que es muy
difícil encontrar médula ósea compatible
y porque os preguntareis pues porque hay
muy poquitos donantes y es bastante
triste porque todos tenemos médula de
sobra es más estamos produciendo la
continuamente así que dar un poquito
para alguien que la necesita es gratis
la única razón por la que no lo hacemos
es seamos en estos pereza y el primero
en entonar el 'mea culpa' soy yo en
otras palabras que no hay ninguna excusa
razonable para no salvar la vida de un
niño y os preguntaréis cómo puedo donar
médula ósea pues muy fácil buscáis en
google donar médula ósea en vuestro país
llamáis al centro de donantes que
tengáis más cerca y pedís una cita
ahí os harán unas pruebas y os meterán
en un registro internacional si hay
alguien en cualquier lugar del mundo que
necesite vuestra médula o samaranch para
que vayáis a donar es verdad que el
proceso es un poquito doloroso y puede
es ser más complicado que simplemente
donar sangre pero repito tenemos médula
ósea de sobra y podemos salvar una vida
desde luego yo ya he pedido una cita y
vosotros pues no esperéis más en cuanto
terminéis este vídeo abrís una pestañita
en el navegador y pedís una cita que no
se diga que en visual politics somos
unos perezosos y ahora sí vamos a ver un
poco de historia
el capitalismo francés versus
capitalismo alemán los que lleváis
tiempo suscritos a visual política
recordaréis este vídeo en el que
hablábamos de francia francia es la
patria de los croissants las baguettes y
el dirigismo económico desde la época de
charles de gaulle el capitalismo francés
es como dirigir la economía al estilo de
un ejército por supuesto que hay
empresas privadas y en cierto sentido
tienen competencia pero durante décadas
la filosofía económica en francia es que
el estado tiene que proteger y ayudar a
sus grandes empresas
montar una empresa nueva en este país
puede ser un dolor de cabeza ahora bien
una vez eres grande el estado te pone la
alfombra roja es más recordáis que os
decía que de las 50 empresas más grandes
del mundo sólo 8 son europeas pues bien
de esas 8 empresas 3 son francesas y
esto no es casualidad
el capitalismo alemán es todo lo
contrario por supuesto que en alemania
hay regulaciones y tienen impuestos pero
en este caso las leyes económicas están
pensadas para proteger un bien superior
el medio ambiente los derechos laborales
o la competencia queréis un ejemplo pues
os doy un ejemplo la política energética
si recordáis en este otro vídeo os
contábamos que alemania está totalmente
en contra de la energía nuclear por
razones ecológicas eso significa entre
otras cosas que producir electricidad en
este país es bastante caro sin embargo
francia es el país nuclear por
antonomasia ningún otro país tiene
tantas centrales nucleares
eso significa que en principio francia
podría producir energía más barata
verdad pues nada de eso si entráis en
next patishtán puntocom podéis ver que
la factura de la luz en múnich es
prácticamente idéntica a la de parís y
esto porque ocurre pues por razones como
ésta un grupo de defensa de consumidores
franceses dice que el monopolio de edf
está subiendo los precios exacto para
que os hagáis una idea en alemania hay
un montón de empresas energéticas y
ninguna tiene participación del estado
bueno vale hay una pequeña excepción que
sería peón pero sólo tiene un 2 por
ciento del accionariado en manos de un
gobierno regional el resto son
completamente privadas y compiten al
mismo nivel sin embargo en francia hay
un gran gigante que se llama edf y el 70
por ciento del accionariado de edf está
en manos del gobierno francés esto
significa un apoyo enorme y unas
condiciones de prácticamente monopolio
[Música]
por supuesto que no todo es malo gracias
al apoyo público edf es la tercera
empresa más grande del mundo de hecho
están presentes en muchísimos países
tanto en europa como en áfrica
el precio de ser tan grande lo pagan los
consumidores franceses y lo mismo pasa
con otros sectores por ejemplo los
automóviles francia tiene dos grandes
gigantes del sector
renault y el grupo peugeot citroën
muchos podéis pensar que son empresas
privadas que compiten en el mercado
libre como cualquier otra verdad pues no
del todo
veréis en ambos casos el gobierno de
francia es uno de los principales
accionistas en el caso de renault el
estado francés tiene el 15% del capital
todo esto significa un colchón económico
enorme que viene directamente de los
impuestos de todos los franceses gracias
a este apoyo
renault tiene una posición de partida
mucho más cómoda que otras marcas de
coches
[Música]
pero no solo es a tener tantísimas
acciones el estado puede intervenir
directamente en las decisiones de la
empresa por ejemplo parís nunca
permitiría que renault terminará en
manos extranjeras y muchas veces el
estado ha vetado el cierre de fábricas o
incluso han dado subvenciones para
desarrollar nuevos modelos de coches sin
embargo qué pasa en alemania pues en
este caso el gobierno alemán no tiene
acciones de ninguna empresa de coches
por ejemplo bmw es totalmente privada y
volkswagen está participada por un
ayuntamiento pero es totalmente
independiente del estado es decir que
alemania ni ayuda ni deja de ayudar a
sus empresas y algo parecido ocurre en
los países nórdicos y eso explica
noticias como esta
[Música]
chile holdings completa la adquisición
de las acciones de polvo en este caso
hablamos de un grupo chino comprando una
de las empresas más grandes de toda
suecia el gobierno sueco no dijo ni esta
boca es mía todo esto sería impensable
en francia no sólo es que haya un sinfín
de regulaciones contra la inversión
extranjera es que además el estado sería
accionista y bloquearía cualquier
adquisición extranjera pero sin duda
alguna donde mejor se ve esta diferencia
de mentalidad es en la historia que os
vamos a contar ahora mismo
[Música]
el gigante sobre raíles por cierto que
esto tan bonito que está sonando es la
música de hardware un grupo alemán de
rock duro que nos ha enviado su musical
[Música]
concretamente este tema que escucháis se
llama neuman slam en tierra de natividad
[Música]
y es que hubo un momento donde china era
una tierra de nadie' para las empresas
el país crecía como la espuma
necesitaban carreteras puentes y trenes
pero no tenían empresas propias que los
pudieran construir así que en 2004
siemens consiguió un acuerdo millonario
para construir trenes de alta velocidad
en china el problema pues que los chinos
negocian como nadie una de las
condiciones que pusieron es que por cada
ingeniero alemán que estuviera en el
proyecto tenía que haber uno chino
conclusión los chinos aprendieron
enseguida cómo fabricar trenes de alta
velocidad
años más tarde siemens terminó el
contrato y china ya tenía lo que quería
tecnología y con esta tecnología crearon
su propia empresa de fabricación de
trevés crrc y no hablamos de una empresa
cualquiera
[Música]
hablamos de un auténtico gigante de
proporciones nacho vidal yang as
[Música]
efe rc el gigante sobre raíles chinos al
que europa tiene miedo la corporación
genera unos ingresos de 26 mil millones
de euros en 2017 pues exactamente en el
mundo de las empresas el tamaño importa
con todo ese dinero crrc es la empresa
más grande del sector puede hacer
grandes inversiones y comerse a los
competidores ya han conseguido contratos
en eeuu
serbia y república checa- así que qué
piensa un francés cuando quiere hacer
frente a un competidor extranjero pues
esto
[Música]
la alemana siemens y la francesa alstom
se fusionarán para crear un nuevo
campeón ferroviario europeo para que os
hagáis una idea esta empresa iba a ser
la segunda más grande del sector a nivel
mundial y os preguntaréis dónde iban a
tener su sede pues exacto en parís así
que todos estaban contentos los
accionistas el gobierno de francia y el
gobierno de alemania el problema el
problema son las leyes antimonopolio
básicamente si dos empresas grandes se
fusionan necesitan una autorización
especial en europa el límite para
determinar que es grande que no lo es
son cinco mil millones de euros de
facturación y 250 millones de euros de
facturación dentro de europa
sin empresa que surge de esta fusión
rebasa esos límites necesita pedir
permiso a la comisión europea y ahí es
cuando nuestros amigos de alstom siemens
se toparon con la señora marguerite
vestager
[Música]
esta ya dice no a la megafusión siemens
alstom vestager es la comisaria de
competencia algo así como la ministra
del gobierno de europa
encargada de regular a las grandes
empresas aunque sea una política danesa
podríamos decir que vestager es la
principal representante del capitalismo
alemán su argumento es que alstom
siemens serían los gente mente grande
como para barrer al resto de pequeñas
empresas de trenes
[Música]
pensad que además hablamos de un sector
muy conectado a los estados casi todos
los trenes que se construyen en europa
están pagados por los gobiernos así que
imagina quién ganaría todos los
concursos públicos tanto en francia como
alemania y aquí es donde llega el gran
dilema
[Música]
el ministro de economía francés bruno le
maire ha defendido vívidamente la fusión
de alstom siemens la unión europea
estaría cometiendo un enorme error
político y económico si rechaza la
fusión como os podéis imaginar tanto el
gobierno de francia como el de alemania
han hecho toda la presión posible para
que saliera a la fusión
[Música]
su argumento era que sin alstom siemens
los chinos terminarían fabricando todos
los trenes europeos el argumento de best
ayer era que la mejor forma de hacer
frente a china es con innovación y que
para eso es mejor tener muchas empresas
compitiendo entre sí así que ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros quién tiene
razón que habrías hecho vosotros
habríais aceptado la fusión
alstom siemens creéis que europa
necesita ayudar a sus empresas para que
se conviertan en gigantes económicos
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribirse a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones
y ahora que ha terminado el vídeo ya no
tenéis excusa todos a buscar ya pedir
cita para registrarse y donar médula
ósea no esperéis más wakaso vais a dejar
de salvar una vida solo por pereza al
abrir la pestañita en el navegador ahora
mismo y pedido una cita en vuestro
centro de donación más próximo y ahora
sí un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]